nah girl idea I heard about Hamilton I
heard it was really good but I heard
nothing specific about Hamilton it was a
musical I was like musical and one of my
best friends watched it he was like no
no it's really good and you would like
it so I watched it it was really good
and I liked it so let's talk about it
[Music]
so Hamilton's a stage production but
it's a film stage production it's not
like lame is it's a movie version of a
stage production does not like that this
is like a filmed stage productions
really well filmed - I mean it's written
by lin-manuel Miranda he also wrote the
music for it he also plays Alexander
Hamilton but before I gushed about the
music I got to give props to Thomas Kael
who directed this because the best seat
in the house to watch Hamilton is now
your living room because it's just
optimally filmed though the best seat in
the house for the music of Hamilton
would be in person so if you're gonna
watch Hamilton have a killer sound
system because that's the fun of
musicals but all right so it being a
stage production Hamilton is a musical
version of the story of Alexander
Hamilton a founding father of the United
States
you know Hamilton Aaron Burr everything
we learned not from public education but
a milk commercial not even a named milk
commercial but you know generally got
milk no specific brand any brand will do
there you go history lesson
good job public education unbelievable
but in that it being a musical it's not
how you would think the musical would be
in a musical about Alexander Hamilton a
founding father of America because I
know I thought it would be like we wrote
a declaration a declaration of
independence no nothing like that it has
a great modern hip-hop energy to it
which is great stuff because that keeps
the kids from falling asleep in the
classroom when the teacher inevitably
shows them this that's good what's right
mad stage production recorded naptime
that's what I thought but it's really
engaging it's two hours and 40 minutes
it kept me engaged the entire time every
word and Hamilton is sung but that's to
say they're back to back musical numbers
it's two hours and 40 minutes of
back-to-back musical numbers it's not
like in between the musical numbers they
still sing their words but it's not part
of a musical number like I got you a
coffee did you want a coffee I did not
want that coffee I wanted one cream and
oh god it's not like that it's just
really engaging energetic music
Alexander Hamilton and Thomas Jefferson
even have a debate that's pretty much
a rap battle innate mind it was genius
this is brilliant but yeah this
production even brought the feels
lin-manuel Miranda was great in Hamilton
for the longest time in here he's pretty
much it revolves around him so you're
like okay he's he's the central piece it
all kinda rests on his shoulders but
that's not completely true because at a
point Thomas Jefferson comes in not that
everyone didn't do a great job at the
ones that stand out are Alexander
Hamilton and Thomas Jefferson Davi Diggs
as Thomas Jefferson just brings this
really douchey energy to it I say that
in the sense that that's one of the
things I liked about this is that
politics were always politics you get a
bunch of stubborn go-get-'em strong
minds together in a room they're gonna
clash from time to time but the snarky
energy Davi Diggs brings to Thomas
Jefferson and the dynamic between him
and Alexander Hamilton it completely
works but in bringing that new energy
also it brings a lot of humor into it
there's one scene in particular I was
like who Disney Bligh's I mean they
don't finish the phrase but it's kind of
like Ferris Bueller's Day Off when that
nurse comes to the door the finishing
line is not something about firetruck
same kind of cutoff happens and arrows
like kids are gonna know what the next
line is I only say that because I knew
what the next line was when I was a kid
and I watched Ferris Bueller's Day Off
but everything from the acting the music
the stage they have this rotating part
of the center stage and they use that
for a couple of shots that they make
look like slow-mo that with the camera
being optimized to film it in a way that
really that comes across for the
audience a lot just really hit with
Hamilton plus I I'm fascinated with the
story it's a fascinating story a group
of people who are like [ __ ] the country
we're just gonna kind of break off and
create our own country and they have a
king spitting on him the entire time in
the stage man there's stuff that about
that HDR
like actually Google it was like
Hamilton King spit wow I did Google just
finish the entire phrase for me yep
those are the Articles that poor guy he
looked like Alan Rickman is the Sheriff
of Nottingham pulling the knife out of
his chest but anyhow the story in the
history I've always found it fascinating
I enjoyed the John Adams mini series on
HBO too and that's pretty
long winded - but still I enjoyed it so
the fact that Hamilton takes it focuses
it up and then injects it with this
modern energy there's modern musical
energy a really Doug Hamilton I hope we
see more film stage productions just you
know become the norm I don't need to see
a movie of The Book of Mormon I just
want to see a film stage production of
The Book of Mormon but now keeps a book
I know there's more out there I just
really liked that one spooky moment hey
I know you can stream it on Disney Plus
but still Hamilton's worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray
all right so Hamilton have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]